mamma mia la sulla
[Applauso]
[Risate]
tenuta oggi a berlino a cosa giochiamo e
sa cosa vuoi giocare berlino team e cosa
fai giocare cosa fare a prendere tutte
le crocchette non so se esiste questo
gioco sono blocks devo controllare
berlino e sostituito vitale oggi farei
un equipe room assieme e cioè recuperare
tutte le crocchette
per adesso io sarei tornato ecco carlino
loro modo accennarli e andate a dormire
di verdetti oggi i nuovissimi ski promo
super divertente dovremmo scappare dal
cuoco cattivo chef cattivone cucinarci e
saremmo in una cucina gigante ci sarà
tutto gigantesco trova attento posso
mangiare tutto quello che voglio anche
formato gigante dare bellissimo perché
successo di cibo è carabiniere a di cibo
che i prof guardate noi stiamo delle
bravate lasciate beh mi piace dice ho
avuto vite l'escape rummo anche gli
orecchini a forma di fragola
eccoci qua io e vitale siamo due credo
che in queste skype rombo vediamo cosa
dobbiamo certo che dice colini con siamo
intrappolati nel frigo scappiamo ecco
perché siamo né lo aspetta
ci sono dei costumi che possiamo
utilizzare quindi noi siamo
più bello per questi ti vogliono i robot
allora io
rimango fragola problemi a forma di
fragola tutte voi quel mare la vela io
faccio la mela allora eccoci qua non è
in ballo
quindi per scappare dal frigo dobbiamo
salire da qua eh sì siamo ad ora le coop
ai derivanti e le con sue miniature e
accaduto al mio il latte equivalente
accellera vitale o
sono bravissimo ormai abbiamo preso darà
di vedere quanta stella livello 2
questo formaggio sembra un po ammuffito
imprese lato noi però forse dobbiamo
passare dal parlamento
quello tre sono già in contanti non ce
n'erano vitali altro operato devo
sbrigarmi adesso scendiamo giù qui ma
quanto è grande e questo frigo lo chef
dice
il freddo che fa qui usiamo ghiaccioli
per scappare ed è giustamente se fa
freddo scavo regina coeli per scappare
ecco perché quasi sono tutti i
ghiaccioli non cadere nel freezer se
noti con sono caduto non sono
di sinistra celato in ritardo lo so
perché
sono riuscito a scappare dal frigo
davvero aspettami io sono ancora qui
bloccato sui ghiaccioli la chef ha detto
benvenuti nella cucina fantastica che
grande questa cucina che
appare da questo mega così abbiamo
subito a riscaldarci allora che cosa c'è
stiamo soltanto sui cracker fi visto sì
è vero e lo chef dice dove la cioccolata
e la cioccolata voglio anch'io si si
troverà vitale sicuramente infatti sono
già avantissimo molto in alto ma siamo
tra l'altro sembrano tipo del rotolo di
carta igienica erano queste cose bianche
rotoli di carta igienica
no mi sono sfracellato al è caduta a qua
è davvero gigante questa cucina d'oro e
non mi rubare tutto il ciclo vitale
località
vitale mela e abbiamo anche messo la
modalità facile anzi sarebbe sfracellati
di lavoro meno 5
sì una banana
come perché già chiesto se siamo una
banana sa perché ma dobbiamo superare le
pareti con le banane
una banana sono ancora vivo non ci credo
sono riuscito ad attraversare tutte le
banane come mai non ti sei fatto
distrarre del cioccolato
veloce veloce saltano g ma vicinissimo a
saltare anche usa fra le banane brava ce
l'ho fatta che cosa dice wow possiamo
volare per 20 secondi con questa teiera
è che senso
ho capito cosa vuole dire riera aspetta
è prova pro polare non parte ecco
bisogna cliccare qua sotto
ma io stavo volato con la teiera vita lo
sfracello
vogliamo rifare tutto da capo
allora io non lo faccio per farmi
bagnare dalla tagliano ma basta forse
venire qui a livello 6 per salvare
arrivo non ti conviene tali
guarda che poi ti sfracelli ecco ho
preso ho preso la mia
la sulla
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
frati per te aspetta anch'io lo vogliono
bene anche caduto come la sla the year
the year è fantastico no non lo posso
più prendere un peccato era troppo
divertente vedere vitale gigante nella
terrina terriera
c'è scritto di non toccare l'impatto
quindi bisogna salire sopra come sigla
c'e qualcosa che non farlo perché io so
e non sono l'impasto non devi sparire
sull'importo devi salire sui mattarelli
devi camminare un po in tenere
l'equilibrio non cadere giù dove vitale
sono qui unico in italia ha spiegato
attenta ma stavo per cadere giù
7 attenti c'è del pad ying dei casalesi
il petting sarebbe apple e cassetti
aspettando
ha dentro bisogna scendere quasi a
toccare quelle cose donne sarà gelato ok
adesso bisogna votarlo
rotolate la farà vitale me l'ha fatto
fare
ecco mi è un pò ingombrante questa mela
non farti distrarre dal cioccolato
dobbiamo esaminare tutto daccapo vero
non sottovento approfittare mail ali non
meno il cioccolato però sono più buone
le fragole al cioccolato che cosa vuoi
dire che mi dava sfracellare
o no non si sbatte per star ma chi sei
tu quella con la teiera no sono altri
giocatori che sono riusciti a prendere
che si
no quindi siamo noi che siamo delle
schiappe che non sappiamo popolare della
carriera ok cielo po di caldo
mi aspetto un 8 eccomi sono arrivato
anch'io vincerà afragola mela riesce a
superare le lattine certo attento come
attento attento testo non dovrebbero
evitare dispiace però forse ho trovato
aiuto non è facendo
diventerà una torta di mele io sono
fatta ci sono ci sono ci sono ecco gli
diamo vita ladies e la paura ce la fa
tappata incredibile che ho fatto non
farti affettare che ci sono dei coltelli
e vogliono farsi a fettine non vedo
l'ora di vedere vitale me l'ha fatto
fare la bella fetta di bella
fantasticano più difficile
strano per ora non mi sono questi no no
abbiamo mangiato a metà
vediamo vitale mela aspettare vitale a
me la sono passato anche io
invece mi sono senza non riuscito a
passare tutti i coltelli ma poi alla
fine mi sono sfracellato del pavimento
dice che dobbiamo salire sulle bolle wow
allora aspetta a scompaiono poi che
vediamo qua comandiamo
attento grazie per il passaggio di ballo
sono caduto non bisogna morire di fame
non lo avevo capito
allora aspetto le altre bolle ecco forse
devo saltare qua sopra
sono finito dentro questa casetta di
marzo porta molto dolce e vediamo se
troviamo qualcosa ma forse meglio se
avete ingoria mangiare non solamente da
mangiare mi piace nostra certamente
qualcosa che sta andando a fuoco bene
babbo natale c'è qui sullo sfondo che la
casa di una strega dobbiamo tornare
nelle balle andiamo vediamo se riusciamo
forse quasi una scorciatoia si no
dobbiamo per forza salire sulle bolle
riuscire a saltare al momento giusto
appena arriviamo lì devi saltare perché
troppo esplodere bisogna saltare di
forlì in bollo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
viviamo dove vitale e coraggio vedetevi
na li mettiamo sempre di più una mela
volare ma perché ti sei posta non aveva
fondato
sfracellato 10 mila volte allora lo chef
dice lo chef dice che dobbiamo trovare
una soluzione noi da storia dell uomo
l'area ci sono nella scatola forse
dobbiamo dinosauri e sulle bolle andiamo
dove si portano qui ci sono delle
scatole però effettivamente
era capito il trucco o no ma la scatola
ti schiaccia non ho praticamente da una
parte ne ha aperta quindi tu devi stare
dalla parte aperta
che termina alto niente io mica così si
è capito quello che ho detto aspettiamo
che passi la scalda la adesso vai vai
vai e adesso ti devi mettere quanto la
scatola torna no no no a te faccio
chiudere nella scatola un'altra e mi
faccio chiederemo io sono passato così
perché potevo farcela vai vai vai
devo fare i motori non è però
diventa ancora più difficile a nuove
sono troppo perdono ho detto
non mi ha spiegato ancora per poco
mettiamo però c'è mancato poco per
entrare nella scatola
spiaccicato da quello dietro
aiuta
ei mappe io tanto sopra l'esca
faccio solo il passato un passato non ce
n'erano sorpassato se lo zio
vitale che si sfracella the presi da
passare come il patto perché sono
bravissimo a rompere le scatole ho
capito bisogna essere molto fatte che si
fece riuscito vitale potremmo riuscirci
anche noi ok briati bailey rae perfetto
a terremoti è vero che le chiamate voce
perché sennò ti schiacciano di dietro
aiuto
l'ultimo questo vai vai vai
[Musica]
guarda un po questo livello abbiamo
dell'intera in rai bisogna evitare
iranico bug e propri fan o sono
carinissimi
[Musica]
a livello 14 dire dice un uomo è
fantastico quanto amo i cereali
ok un labirinto di cereali wow si sono
tantissime scatole di giornalisti hanno
ferito che bello e
coperta e forse fa qui ha chiuso mi sono
perso o no dove mi sento
troviamo quad a questa parte parte
va trovato sia vero
siccome abbiamo qui muovono sono volanti
soprattutto è bello sarebbe mangiarli
tutti al volo tecnico
si è giocata a mangiare ed io no quando
ho sempre più difficile qua non sopporto
mi sono bloccato da poco finito vitale
aiuto
animali oggetti bloccato si è scaricato
il mouse cosa no vabbè ma questo livello
è infinito non si sono mai posti dice un
uomo vicino
accaduto si sono fatti ci sono quasi da
vicino dal forno non devo salvare dovuta
al mare io ho dovuto ricominciare tutto
daccapo da evitare puoi farcela facciamo
il tifo per vitale mela lasciate un mi
piace fa stato per portare fortuna
vitali vero adesso
capisco
erosivi fa dove sono io deve salvare e
come non ti buttare nel forno terreno
diventerai un biscotto mela non ci credo
sono riuscito ad arrivare qui senza
trasformarla in un biscotto allam è la
torta di mele e ora dove dobbiamo andare
a non bisogna andare nel forno ma
dobbiamo aspettare sei tu
ma vediamo cos'è muro quello che prof
contatti che non sono saltato sul posto
sono saltato per
cento una mela che fa
una mission impossible
guarda qua è andato tutto a fuoco no e
dopo prendere un estintore dove dobbiamo
andare forse ho capito dobbiamo
aspettare ecco vedi quando si sente
subito passare però ti devi sbrigare
perché questi reazione quindi l'altra
esatto che sto bruciando
mi sono bruciato devi stare molto
attento quando si apre
una fragola cotta ok ci si siede ora
dove
dovevo
[Musica]
eccoli qua stata fatta salto dove chi
si guarda
ok adesso dobbiamo dargli la ricetta da
un red green white quindi marrone rosso
rosso verde verde bianco qui quindi
dobbiamo alone ma sul marrone poi rosso
no è sbagliato e la ricciola scritto
rosso rosso marrone rosso rosso verde
verde bianco allora marrone
ha bravissima si raffrontano
leone verde rosso verde
verde e bianco
i problemi sono sia una giornata non
guarda qui dobbiamo arrampicarci sugli
spari sugli spaghetti che
scrivete nei commenti qual è il vostro
tipo di pasta preferita
il mio sono gli spaghetti io mangerei
tempo e spaghetti
e il tuo il mio le mezzemaniche io
mangerei sempre mezze maniche ma anche a
penne e spaghetti i bucatini tutta
fatta sì è vero però preferisco le mezze
maniche a vento vado per cadere ma sono
riusciti ad aggrapparmi a c'era un fatto
mai comunale mela e spaghetti
si
no
siamo tutti il tipo per merli
facciamo positivo per me una beffa per
metallici spaghetti lo faccio dare più
forza
povero evitare un po
riuscito a scappare
speriamo sia stata troppo divertente ora
dobbiamo prendere il mezzo uomo c'è una
canna di banane
abbiamo vinto congratulazioni sei
riuscito a scappare dalla cucina bello è
stato super divertente
guarda io ora sono nella vasca da bagno
eccoci ci rilassiamo adesso qui
che è bello e ski promo
raffinato 4 castelli e semplificare per
vedere i nostri altri video cade su
quella che preferite